and goes from talking about hey we got
more content coming and it felt like
story content it felt like they might do
this endless thing which I was super
excited for yeah that's what I wanted
because I didn't want to wait there was
a part of me the part of me that liked
infinite from a live service model was
the fact that I wouldn't have to wait
four or five years to continue my story
like I wanted to continue that let's do
this let's find out what happened with
lock yeah I thought we were going there
so I'm like okay then they don't have
the content to do it and now the person
who I think might be responsible for
good writing and good narrative and good
story which is him now leaves I'm like
uh so now is it going to be just
multiplayer only level drops yeah you
know and it seems maybe that's the case
and it seems you know the Battle Royale
you know I'm just hoping that we get
more story content I don't have to wait
for Halo 7. you know